kevin malone you're next spit that out
spit okay come on let's go you look cute
today boy
thanks girl so yesterday Dwight found
half a joint in the parking lot which is
unfortunate because as it turns out
Dwight finding drugs is more dangerous
than most people using drugs let's go
over some of these symptoms of marijuana
use shall we you tell me who this sounds
like slow-moving inattentive dull
constantly snacking shows a lack of
motivation
I like the people I work with generally
with four exceptions but someone
committed a crime and I did not become a
Lackawanna County volunteer sheriff's
deputy to make friends and by the way I
haven't few days ago on a routine
campaign stop in downtown Pawnee one
Leslie Knope pause was attacked play by
a PI luckily it only hit Jerry so no
damage was done play the only evidence
we have is a video shot by pause my wife
April Ludgate this is Bert Macklin
greatest assignment yet if you are
watching perpetrator just know that you
are still at large okay listen up folks
we have a security situation here as you
know when we reach the location I will
be conducting a security sweep also from
now on we'll be using code names you can
address me as Eagle one and code name
been there done that
April is currently doing that Donna is
it happened once in a dream Kris code
name if I had to pick a dude Ben is
Eagle two oh thank god I've been staring
at this board for days
so close to putting it together there's
gotta be something we missed
let's go over this again the video shows
that the PI came from a high angle so it
would've hit your face like this mm-hmm
don't close your eyes no no it actually
was from up higher is that about right
yeah good clean yourself up let's do
this again all right let's go to the
video again sweet kick Lesley exits the
building and then you get hit what else
do we know we know that Leslie was about
15 feet in front of you
so clearly the assailant has terrible
aim or Leslie wasn't the target
well hold on okay this permanent marker
go find Ben get a list of everyone he's
ever fired go go you son of a [__]
sewage Joe been why fired you for
sending pictures of your penis to
everyone and you've come here to pie him
little tour pass it come in the hall
dude I dare ya
please give you one reason to take you
down
I would love being sorry I did it yeah
great job okay this is the Junior police
program
aka Mission Possible your mission should
you choose to accept it is to get your
life back on track
[Music]
since I have nothing to offer it since
I'm not a cop I thought I'd just show up
and learn you want to help me out here
no I think I'm good I know you think
getting in trouble is cool but let me
show you what can happen if you continue
down this path hey yo I'm an at-risk kid
and I think it's cool to sell drugs huh
what does the kid selling drugs sound
like he's black he's not well why not
are you saying that black people can't
sell drugs no I'm not saying that we
have a black president why can't black
people sell drugs
I'm so confused black people can sell
drugs
I don't know how to connect with these
kids they're mean and shallow and
respect nothing I mean what kind of
person would they even listen to
Hitchcock stop bringing your food in
little Tupperware containers it hurts my
fingers when I'm trying to open it sorry
hey Gina that's a super cute what do you
want sweater okay
Rosa and I think it would be great if
you talked to the kids
I thought only cops could help in this
case not being cop might actually be
better that's true in all cases cops are
the worst children your problem is not
that you're troubled or at-risk or bad
dressers is that a trick or not still
come on your problem is that you don't
have passion for anything my life turned
around when I found my passion and today
well I hope to inspire you with it
[Music]
[Applause]
what are we thinking yes and the denim I
think I speak for everyone when I say
your weird dancing was just weird fine
cops make $52,000 a year you never have
to stop at a red light and you get to
carry a gun
who wants in a little boom boom yes oh
my god I've got eight kids to sign up
how did you know that would work that's
what made me sign up when I was a kid
you did this program mm-hmm yeah it does
not work once a year Dwight holds a
seminar updating us on the newest
developments in the world of karate
because as we all know the one thing
that thousand-year-old martial arts do
all the time is change how can I pose
this to you in a relatable way you are
all members of the Yakuza and you happen
to be visiting the Lackawanna Trolley
Museum and you're attacked by triads how
can you hold them off until your clan
arrives you cannot go wrong with a
throat punch ah okay so there's no
defense for that good to know no there
is a defense for that let me demonstrate
someone attacked me Kevin go no way last
time you pulled my pants down and then
you tried to choke me with my shoelace
false I did choke you with your shoelace
now come at me okay with all due respect
to everyone here I think the most worthy
opponent of you is you that is correct
unless there happened to be measles
present so let's just say that Dwight
has come at you with the throat punch
now how would you do it-- defend against
it easy allow me to demonstrate
i am attacking myself with a throat
punch here it comes
block grasp wrist as such and what if he
comes at you with the other hand because
he does have to good point second throat
punch absorb the blow groin punch hit
block no bones in the gut Oh up to the
nose no you're not aah
Oh oh my God he's making you look like
such a fool he really is but not for
long Oh God instep oh not again
ha ha ha you let go you let go
right look at hold on oh you're so
evenly matched I don't know how one of
you is gonna get the upper hand the
important thing to remember Jen we
always have what is called the element
of surprise
why don't you let me take a run at him
boss in order to think like one of these
guys you have to think like them yeah
he's never seen you before
so imply that you're someone very
important and that you can make his life
hell greg pikitis would you like some
boiling hot coffee face my name is Bert
Macklin I'm with the FBI huh looks like
Andy's wearing him down I'm gonna go
finish him off just shut up for a second
he's a jerk he's being such a jerk to
the awful thing to say too is you would
be are you crying I'm not crying okay
little lerczak two jerks
you